[Music]
hey so welcome back to the next part of
my tutorial on how to easily save
figures in R now I'm going to take the
figure that we worked with last time to
the next level so I'm going to improve
its composition what it looks like make
some adjustments to what type of plot it
actually is to make it a little more
appropriate for the data that we're
trying to visualize and really just give
you a complete walk through to kind of
what my thought process is as I go
through with creating a visualization in
R if you haven't seen my previous video
and part one in this little series that
I have then I suggest checking that out
it's where I go over creating the
initial plot that we're going to be
working with in this video that we're
going to be expanding on and also where
I introduced GG save so if you haven't
seen it check it out there will be a
link in this video and then down below
in the description if you have seen it
and fantastic uh excited to have you
here thanks for watching and let's jump
in
but now I want to like take this one
step further and let's make this plot
quite a bit nicer just so that you can
see kind of what a polished product
might look like together with this GG
save feature that we have
so for that we're going to I'm going to
just
put a little separator here so that we
know that we're starting something a
little new
and for this section I'm going to load
the Tidy verse set of packages which
includes deep plier you could just learn
load
I think we could just load D plier
instead of tidyverse I always like to
load tidy versus it also loads ggplot
and and other useful packages but let's
just try with d plier and again you can
install it using install.packages if you
don't already have D player installed
it's a really powerful tool if you know
about python already and you're just
learning are now the plier is kind of
like the equivalent of pandas in in
Python a lot of useful tools for working
with data frames and data manipulation
let's adjust a few more plot parameters
to make the plot look really good so
we're still going to be working with the
same data and we'll say ggplot
we'll copy this whole thing over
so let's say let's actually make it a so
if we look at the plots again this looks
like it would look better as a box plot
because you have all these points in
these age categories and so grouping all
these points into a box plot each seems
to make a little more sense so let's you
instead of Geon Point Let's do geom
box plot
let's run this first just to see what
that looks like
ah yes the problem is that age it's just
kind of lumping everything together
because it isn't actually
separate categories the way we'd want it
to be so before this let's modify the
pine data a little bit let's say
let's do pine data
so we're taking this raw Loblolly data
I'm going to add a pipe so piping is
also another useful which actually is
not part of the deep plier Library so
let's try this just to see what happens
um maybe it is part of the D player
Library let's see it might a bunch of
changes have happened recently where
they've added uh when you load uh deep
plier or it's possible that I had
already loaded tidy verse
just to be sure so actually this is a
really good exercise something that
sometimes happens is you'll write code
you delete some things then you run it
again it's still working and then you
reopen rstudio and you run the code and
it doesn't work anymore and that's
because you ran something in the past
that you deleted since deleted but it's
still in the environment so for example
you loaded a certain package and I think
the reason this pipe is working is or
that I didn't get an error that tells me
it doesn't know what this means I got a
different kind of error here but the
fact that I didn't get an error that
tells me this that says this doesn't
know what this means suggests that
perhaps I had loaded tidy verse
previously and when I was playing around
in this script and then removed it to
run d-plier instead whenever you're
working with our code and and Hadley
Wickham is a big proponent of this you
can basically restart your our session
and there's some other fancy ways of
doing it but let's just restart R by
just clicking here and this resets the
Enviro environment it resets the
plotting area it says restarting our
session right here so now we're going to
have to rerun a few things so we're
gonna have to rerun ggplot2 let's put
this all down here so that all the code
is nice and together we're going to
rerun the Loblolly data to get that okay
so let's run D plier to load that
let's load ggplot2 let's load the
Loblolly data set
and now let's see if the pipes work so
let's actually finish this so what I was
going to say here was let's use mutate
to change age to a factor
so that will allow us to have like these
different box plots based on these
different age groupings
so now if we run this
oh look at that it worked okay so this
is telling me that there's been some
recent changes in D plier perhaps that
now load or in ggplot2 perhaps that load
this which used to be part of the
magriter
um
package which isn't loaded and yet
somehow it knows anyway if anyone knows
the answer to this please comment down
below curious to know why it might be
something with the new version of D
player anyway so this worked and now if
we take a look at the pine data we can
actually click on this little arrow here
to see what these different what the
different data types here so height is
still numeric but now age is a factor
with six levels so if we just run
Pine data
age
these are the values and then here we
have levels 3 5 10 15 20 and 25.
excellent okay so now if we run this box
plot now it should separate age into the
separate boxes and let's see if this
worked and it did there we go so we have
a separate box plot for each of these
different ages excellent now something
else some of you might know that I have
this big pet peeve against the default
theme of ggplot it's actually what kept
me from going into ggplot2 for a really
long time a lot of people were saying oh
you can make really beautiful plots with
ggplot but I always thought that the
default looked kind of ugly it just kind
of felt like it was this unnecessary
gray area it wasn't simple and and
intuitive to look at some people love it
offhand it's just my personal preference
I really didn't like the way this looked
so you might use a theme such as theme
classic
which will look much more like the bass
R theme
there you have it a little easier to
kind of see the Simplicity of the figure
some people might prefer the Grid in
this case because it does easily because
of the kind of far distance between
everything it might be important to be
able to easily quickly match up with
these ages and Heights actually are on
the two different axes so to adjust that
let's actually bring in a modified theme
that I like to use so here is I'll just
copy and paste it here I'll add it to
the comments below so you can copy and
paste it and use it as well so I call
this theme theme frame because it
adjusts the the sizing of the fonts the
the the margins around the figure it
really overall creates this much more
appealing proportion and composition to
the figures and what's cool about
ggplot2 is that you can create this
theme these theme settings save it and
then apply it to any plot that you want
to apply it to so there's a lot of
pre-built themes but this one I like to
use on top of any other theme that I'm
using because it really only just has to
do with adjusting the proportions and
margins of everything so I call it theme
frame because it kind of frames out the
plot
we've got the plot margin which adds
some margins around the entire plot the
axis text on the x-axis sets it to size
11 on the y-axis size 11 but then the
label for each for each margin is
axis.title so this sets it to a little
bit bigger and then adds some margins
around that and then finally the plot
title which in this case we don't have a
plot title but you can also I also set
the size of that so this I might run you
know sort of along with when I load my
libraries kind of one of the first
things I'll run
run that and then
I will
just add this here right after theme
classic I'll just do a plus and because
it's my own theme that I created I don't
actually need it's not actually a
function so I'm not going to add those
parentheses there
and let's see what this looks like now
there we go so it's not a huge change it
really just changes the again the
margins and the proportions of the text
size is a bit to make it compositionally
a little bit more appealing much much
much closer to a publication ready
figure so just to flip between these two
so you can see again this is what it
looks like before text is really small
not really a lot of breathing room
around the margins now it's a little bit
more compositionally sound
uh and of course you can play around
with these numbers to to adjust it to
your liking however you want or or add
other theme elements here that you want
to modify and adjust create your whole
entire amazing theme from scratch do
whatever you want this is just uh kind
of a proof of concept here to show you
how you can make a nice looking figure
and then the magic sauce save it with GG
save so let's go on and let's actually
let's do a few more things here so I'm
gonna actually in this case I think I'm
going to actually remove there's a few
other adjustments I want to do okay so
I'm going to remove theme classic
because I think in this case the grid is
actually a little bit better
yeah that does look a little bit nicer
because the grid does help you kind of
Orient with respect to height and age
but I want to add to adjust these axes a
little bit more so I'm going to say
scale
y continuous
so scale y continuous is one way to
adjust anything on the y-axis that that
forms a continuous set of values so in
this case since there are all they are
all continuous they're not categorical
so we're going to say
scale y continuous
breaks equals
sequence
we're going to go from 0 to 100 by tens
so here we're going by 20s it kind of
starts around 10 and goes to about 60 70
or so let's just go from 0 to 100 by 10
so that's the sequence if we just run
this function just as a quick reminder
that just creates this sequence of
values that go from 0 to 100 by 10 and
so instead of writing out all these
numbers I'm just using this function and
and breaks tells us where we want the
marker labels for the y-axis
so we run this
and see now we have this nicer set of
values and note because we're just
saying create these breaks between 0 and
ggplot is smart and it still only shows
us you know kind of the relevant area
that encompasses our data and doesn't
actually go from zero to one hundred per
se and then let's add some actual
meaningful labels instead of just height
and age let's add the units in as well
so we'll say labs
x equals
tree age
in
years
and then y equals
height in feet
great so I think that's and don't forget
the plus here and make sure it adds all
the different elements together
let's run this
excellent okay now here's the thing what
I was saying before at the very
beginning was that you could save this
by going save as image but the problem
is look if I do this
um and or do that and then go to export
save as PDF it will save it exactly in
the proportion that we're looking at
right here which is not what we want we
want something consistent regardless of
how our studio is set up how big this
window is set up we want to save a PDF
the same size each time we run it the
other thing I always say and I keep
mentioning PDF is that PDF is the best
way to save your figures in R because it
preserves all of the resolution so
they're essentially they've got
essentially an infinite resolution
meaning that it's basically a vectorized
image so the more you zoom in on it
you'll still see the same lines it won't
become pixelated so if you save it as a
PDF a lot of times when you submit
Publications they'll want the image
either as a really high resolution Tiff
or a PDF because as a PDF it retains all
of its resolutions so General good rule
of thumb always save as a PDF but if you
do this it'll only save it in the
proportion or in the aspect ratio that
you see here or and also the size that
you see here so if you make it really
big see this kind of looks again
proportionally not that great with the
numbers being very small so let's use GG
save
so the way that GG save works is it
saves the last image that you plotted
you don't actually add it in as with a
plus to the digiplot sequence although
that would be kind of cool it just saves
the last figure that you created so
let's save this now as my Pine
plot let's save it as a 4x6 what in
inches was a good proportion good size
to save this
dot PDF
so width
equals 4 height
equals six as you're playing around with
this another way to actually take
advantage of both this little clicking
method and saving it as GG save is the
first time you ever save it you might
want to kind of play around and see what
size is best you might have no idea and
it takes a while to save it and then you
go and open it and then you try again
and it you have to keep going back and
forth instead you can just go to here
save as image even though you're not
going to actually save it as this image
and you can play around with what looks
really good so in this case let's do
something like
I don't know something like that is what
looked good
here it has the size in points or pixels
rather than in inches but either way
this is kind of how I figured out the
ratio that made the most sense
you can update you can also edit these
values here and then update the preview
I'm not going to actually save it I'm
just going to click cancel but I think
let's see let's see if we can do this
PDF to ah yeah okay so with PDF here we
do have it in inches so what we can do
is
say
4 by
6 and we want it in portrait so I play
around with these different sizes until
I found this one looked good and I'm not
going to click save I'm just going to
click preview I'm going to pull this in
this is kind of big a little smaller so
that proportion looked good and the
reason I made it a lot taller is this
tiny little box plot here was all
scrunched up and you couldn't really see
much of it so I figured it seemed more
valuable to have this be stretched
upright in a portrait like that so yeah
so that that sizing looked about right
again I'm not going to save it this way
even though in this case it would create
the same thing but I'm again for
reproducibility for ease for the fact
that you can have this one line of code
right in here that does it all for you
I'm just going to leave it like that and
say
units equals
inches
and let's just run this one more time to
make sure that that's the last figure we
were in and then save it
okay now let's go to files
my Pine plot 4x6
Pull It in here
let's make it a little bit smaller so we
can see it on the screen and there it is
so that's it if you enjoyed this video
be sure to like it comment down below if
you have any questions or or shared the
figures that you were able to create and
save with GG save be sure to subscribe
if you want to see more videos like this
I'm really excited to continue producing
these videos and the more people that
subscribe and show interest the more I'm
going to be doing that so really
appreciate your support if you like this
and want to learn more I've got both
free and paid resources on my website at
rfreecology.com where you can enroll in
my basics of our for ecologists course
which is a complete Essentials course
that takes you by the hand from the very
beginning on how to install r r studio
all the way through data visualization
and being able to really manipulate and
Wrangle your data like a professional in
R so I go through through basically all
the essentials that you need to get a
solid foundation in working with r as an
ecologist but then I also have my intro
to data visualization with our free
ecologists which is aimed at someone
that maybe already knows the very basics
of R but wants to take their data
visualization skills to the next level
with that said the links are here in
this video there's going to be links
down below if you want to check out my
courses or if you want to check out my
blog or other YouTube videos there's a
lot of information and I try to make it
as accessible as possible to everyone so
again thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you in the next video
foreign
[Music]